there are just three days before
england shuts down once again and for
all the pain that will bring
there are many people who feel the same
as elainey and joey in birmingham
they accept the changes albeit with a
weary sense of resignation
i was actually about to go back to work
um
the cafe organ was about to open on
wednesday
um so i was quite excited about that and
now i'm a bit
you know dying inside again um
but yeah if it needs to happen it needs
to happen i think it's important to
remember that the people making these
decisions are only human
but when he addresses parliament later
boris johnson should expect
no such generosity of spirit a growing
number of his own back benches are
voicing their opposition to his plans
while labour are criticizing him for not
acting sooner
later he's expected to tell mps unless
we act now we could see deaths over the
winter that are twice as bad or more
compared with the first wave
faced with these latest figures there is
no alternative but to take further
action at a national level
but he will also defend his decision not
to impose a circuit breaker locked down
last month
as scientists had advised he'll say i
know some in the house believe we should
have reached this decision earlier
but i believe it was right to try every
possible option to get this virus under
control at a local level
he'll also seek to reassure his
backbenchers that the new lockdown will
end on december the second
despite this comment from michael gove
is that yes
yes so it could be it could be extended
yes
but the concerns of conservative rebels
go much wider
the chairman of the influential
backbench 1922 committee
likening measures to those of a
dictatorship
we even now have the government telling
people who they're allowed to sleep with
or not depending on whether they're
deemed to be in an established
relationship
or not if these kind of
measures were being taken in any
totalitarian country around the world
we would be denouncing it as as a form
of evil
also tapping into that sentiment another
familiar thorn in the side of
conservative governments
nigel farage nigel farage has confirmed
the brexit party
is to be renamed reform uk its new focus
fighting lockdowns thank you all very
much
stay safe thank you that will not stop
the new restrictions coming into effect
this week
and neither will parliament but it
amounts to a political backlash
the prime minister will feel unable to
ignore
tom rayne at sky news westminster